In the 1500s and 1600s, the work of Copernicus
and Galileo, among many others, reshaped how
natural philosophers in western Europe thought
about the question, where are we?
But there’s another question to consider
that’s at least equally daunting, what is
life?
And to try to answer that question, three
tools stand out as being especially useful:
...a really long book full of beautifully
grotesque illustrations based on dissected
bodies…
...experiments about blood pumping through
living animals…
...and the microscope.
[Intro Music Plays]
You could call Andreas Vesalius the Copernicus
of anatomy: his name has become synonymous
with a revolution of its own, and his major
book even came out in 1543, the same year
as De rev.
Vesalius was born in Brussels in 1514.
He studied at the Universities of Leuven,
Paris, and Padua.
He wrote his thesis about al-Rāzī, the famous
and prolific medieval physician who wrote
Doubts About Galen.
And Vesalius did some Galen-doubting of his
own.
After conducting years of medical research,
Vesalius wrote up his findings in a gigantic,
seven-volume book with 273 illustrations.
It was published in 1543 under the name De
Humani corporis fabrica, or On the Fabric
of the Human Body.
And it redefined the long Hippocratic–Galenic–Arabic–Persian
medical tradition.
It didn’t just tweak Galen’s ideas.
Fabrica was a new way of doing medicine—a
new paradigm.
The seven books of Fabrica cover the bones
and cartilage, the ligaments and muscles,
the veins and arteries, the nerves, the heart, the brain, and “the
organs of nutrition and generation”—meaning
most of the stuff in the body.
And along the way, it brims with observations
that were new to Vesalius’s world.
Vesalius accurately described the sternum,
the bones of the arm, the skull, and the entire
muscular system.
Importantly, he also wrote that the brain
and nerves are the center of the mind.
This overturned the Aristotelian idea that
the heart was the center of thought and feeling.
And, despite possible religious objections,
Vesalius disproved the belief that men had
one rib fewer than women.
He even disproved the idea, from Galen, that
men have more teeth than women.
Seems like fairly easy things to do!
No one had thought to look inside of a woman's mouth.
That's just way too weird!
How are you gonna study a woman??? Where are they?
In fact, Vesalius realized that many of Galen’s
observations, made back in Roman times—when
human dissection was illegal—had actually
been observations of animals, not humans.
Galen incorrectly thought the human lower
jaw was made of two bones, like it is in some animals.
He thought the major blood vessels started
in the liver.
And he thought the human body had a network
of blood vessels at the base of the brain,
called a rete mirable, that are actually found
in dolphins and sheep.
But Vesalius was able to correct a lot of
this misconceptions, thanks to the big innovation
he used in his lectur-at Padua: dissection.
Instead of hiring a surgeon to do his dirty
work, Vesalius—a scholar—conducted dissections himself.
Thought Bubble, Show us the wonder of hands-on medical observation.
Fabrica is written as a sort of guide to dissecting someone.
Vesalius clearly explains the order in which
you have to dissect a body to observe each muscle.
He lets you know what tools you need.
So Fabrica shows how important instruments
are to scientific knowledge-making.
And over the course of its thousands of pages,
you see that Vesalius began to think about
the human body as a composite of physical,
mechanical, interlocking systems—and not
a bag of humors.
In some ways, “anatomy” in the modern
sense begins with Fabrica.
The book wasn’t just an encyclopedia of
diseases and treatments.
It was a guide for seeing the body anatomically
instead of humorally.
And Vesalius wanted others to see what he
saw.
His book’s illustrations were made possible
by advances in artistic techniques and the
improvement of detailed woodcut engraving
as ahtechnology.
And Vesalius supervised the whole process
carefully.
He wrote out such specific instructions for
his printer that the printer included them
in the text.
Chances are you’ve seen some of the dissection-inspired
woodcuts from Fabrica: flayed human bodies
traipse through a stylized Italian countryside,
making dance-like motions, demonstrating how
their muscles and bones connect, and looking…
not too bad for people with no skin.
Thanks Thought Bubble,
Where Vesalius helped readers of his book
see the human body differently, they would
still have had many questions about what life
is and how it functions.
William Harvey answered one of the big ones—how
does blood work?
Harvey was born in Kent, England, in 1578.
He studied in Italy, was a fellow of the Royal
College of Physicians in London, gave popular
lectures on anatomy, and served as physician
to King James the First.
He also was a major skeptic when it came to
witchcraft, which was the source of much freaking
out at the time.
So, as an official examiner of witches, which
was a thing you could be back then, he acquitted the accused
rather than having them burned alive.
But William Harvey is most famous for his
theory of blood circulation, which Galen and
Vesalius both got wrong.
Like Vesalius, Harvey learned a lot about
bodies through careful observation, AKA getting gettin' all gross.
He did this specifically through vivisection,
or cutting open live animals.
He watched their hearts slow down and finally
stop beating as they died, and he estimated
the amount of blood that left those exposed
hearts.
And he used those measurements for a reason:
to help him formulate medicines.
In doing so, Harvey helped bring the the idea
of rigorous measurement to medical investigation.
And by 1618, Harvey had arrived at the conclusion
that arterial and venous blood vessels form
a single, connected, closed circulatory system.
This was a brand new idea!
Harvey published his findings in 1628, in
another Latin-language classic which sounds
a little bit like you’re casting a spell
when you say it:
Exercitatio Anatomica de Motu Cordis et Sanguinis
in Animalibus, or On the Motion of the Heart
and Blood.
Which historians tend to shorten to De Motu
Cordis.
Which is the name of my new metal band.
De Motu Cordis was, again, a revolt against
the old Aristotelian–Galenic system.
It’s also a great early example of comparative
anatomy:
Harvey compared the hearts and arteries of
many cold-blooded animals in order to understand
the basics of how a heart pumps blood—or,
really, that heart does pump at all -- as
opposed to the blood “diffusing” through
the system as Galen thought.
Through his quantitative experiments, Harvey
disproved the Galenic idea that the liver
creates the blood found in veins.
And Harvey figured out that blood flows in
one direction at a time, thanks to valves.
Also not part of Galen’s system.
But, while Harvey’s De Motu Cordis was a
more accurate theory of how blood circulates
than Galen’s, Harvey also fudged his data
in order to make his point.
When he measured a heart, Harvey estimated
the volume of liquid it could hold, how much
blood it moved each time it beat, and the
number of beats it made in half an hour.
And Harvey made each of these estimates intentionally
low, so that people could easily see how wrong
Galen’s liver-based system was.
The liver simply couldn’t make enough blood,
fast enough, for the diffusion theory to work.
But he made sure that the numbers didn’t
come close.
Now, still, to his credit, Harvey did all
of that observational and experimental work
without a critical instrument that would soon
be developed over in the Low Countries—the
microscope.
Anton Philips van Leeuwenhoek was born in
Delft, in what was then the Dutch Republic,
in 1632.
The inventor of the microscope became the
so-called “father” of microbiology, because
you can’t have a “microbiology” without
a microscope -- another example of the importance
of instrumentation to scientific knowledge-making.
We don’t have all the details of what process
Van Leeuwenhoek used to create his invention.
But we do know he made hundreds of magnifying
lenses and at least twenty-five proper microscopes.
Somewhere along the line, Van Leeuwenhoek
told a doctor friend about his investigation
of the very small, and that friend told the
Royal Society over in England.
In 1673, the Philosophical Transactions of
the Royal Society published van Leeuwenhoek’s
microscope-enabled observations.
A few years of debate ensued about whether
van Leeuwenhoek was pulling everyone’s collective
natural–philosophical chain, but members
of the Royal Society eventually confirmed
his findings.
Using his invention, van Leeuwenhoek discovered
an entire world of amazing forms in miniature.
He found single-celled organisms living their
best lives at an entirely different
scale than our own.
He called these “animalcules” or “little
animals‚” many of which aren’t actually
animals.
For example, in 1677, van Leeuwenhoek observed
spermatozoa.
And in 1682, he observed muscle fibers.
Over the years, he wrote hundreds of letters
to the Royal Society and similar institutions
to share his observations.
But he never divulged the secret of his microscope-manufacturing.
...Jerk!
Another Dutch natural philosopher combined
the work of van Leeuwenhoek and Vesalius.
Jan Swammerdam was born in Amsterdam, in the
Dutch Republic, in 1637.
And, yes, I said that without laughing.
He delicately dissected animal and plant tissues
under a microscope, learning in the process
about both the structure and the development
of life.
This was a critical turn in the life sciences.
Swammerdam observed, for example, how an insect
changes from an egg into a wriggly larva,
then a hibernating pupa, and finally an adult,
often capable of flight.
Four different bodies from one animal!
Swammerdam also experimented on muscle contraction.
And, in 1658, he was the first to observe
red blood cells.
All told, seventeenth-century Holland was
a rad time to be a natural philosopher, asking
“what is life?”
As long as you can get your hands on one of Van Leeuwenhoek's microscopes... which apparently only 26 people could.
But perhaps the greatest early microscopist
was the English polymath Robert Hooke, born
on the Isle of Wight in 1635.
Hooke became the curator of experiments of
the Royal Society and did a whole bunch of
amazing work in science that we’ll have
to explore some other time.
For now, just google “Micrographia.”
This is the book Hooke published in 1665,
which was the first book of microscope-enabled
observations of the natural world, and arguably
the first scientific bestseller.
It’s also the first instance of the word
“cell” being used to describe a single
chamber within a living tissue—like the
cell, or small, confined quarters inhabited
by a monk.
Like Vesalius, who was obsessed with woodcuts,
and van Leeuwenhoek, who was a manic letter
writer, Hooke wanted others to see the living
world how he saw it.
So Micrographia is full of beautiful, tattoo-worthy
illustrations, including a famous one of the
homely flea.
In fact, it’s so beautiful that it’s easy
to forget that, even though it was a scientific
rendering, it was still highly subjective.
After all, seeing nature through a device
like a microscope or telescope doesn’t make
you free from your biases.
And the microscope raised more questions than
the slightly older telescope, because it required
even more subjective interpretation.
With only a few good microscopes around in
Hooke’s day, most readers of Micrographia
couldn’t have confirmed the accuracy of
Hooke’s drawing of a flea, or of anything
else in that book.
They just had to trust in the authority of
the professional scientist—one of the first
in his society.
Next time—we’ll follow so-called “explorers”
from Eurasia as they travel throughout the
Americas and Africa, pillaging, classifying,
and… mostly pillaging.
Stay tuned!
Crash Course History of Science is filmed in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula, Montana and it’s made with the help of all this nice people
and our animation team is Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production. If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly with us,
you can check out some of our other channels like Healthcare Triage,  How to Adult, and Scishow Psych.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course free for everybody, forever, you can support the series at Patreon;
a crowdfunding platform that allows you to support the content you love. Thank you to all of our patrons for making Crash Course possible with their continued support.